Speaker 1: Just a little final note
on the Trump executive privilege stuff
and just Trump's state of mind right now. We
haven't talked about this for months because
it just hasn't been newsworthy. But Donald
Trump continues to publish trash. Agit trash,
I think, is the way I would refer to it
on his website. Donald J. Trump. Just so
you know what's happening, and if you don't care,
that's fine. But just, you know what's happening.
Donald Trump published seven statements yesterday
to his to his news page. Look at some of these.
In case you missed it. New immigration numbers
prove Biden border crisis is worst in history.
No surprise, and it's a link to an article with
the right wing Federalist. Later in the day,
in case you missed it, Newt Gingrich interviews
Mollie Hemingway on the rigged election
lays out a very clear case for the very rigged and
corrupt presidential election where almost a year
out, folks, he's still going. Post number three,
yesterday, GOP pollster predicts Trump would beat
Biden or Harris in a landslide right now link to
New York Post article New York Post, of course,
Fox News News Corp.. Same company Trump posts an
article the confusing Mr. Biden. It's like his
blog. In case you missed it, Biden has no answers
to the nation's problems except empty promises.
Another New York Post article another post. Trump
us being poisoned by illegal immigrants crossing
the border from the New York Post. In case you
missed it, explosive revelations in Wisconsin's
2020 election audit report. And this is just the
beginning. Other swing states are even far worse.
Is this what Trump is relegated to now because
he's not on Twitter like his? Is this just a guy
clinging to the last gasps at attention?
Someone sent me an interesting clip yesterday,
and it was a clip of this hard right young right
winger Nick Fuentes. And even Fuentes was saying,
This is a weird period for Trump, and he's kind
of struggling for relevance. I actually think
that that's an understatement, but accurate.
He's struggling not only for relevance,
but he's even struggling to maintain any kind of
presence in national media. Now, that doesn't mean
we count this guy out. If Trump is do well in
2022 and Trump's healthy going into 24, he very
well may run now. I know when I spoke to Michael
Cohen. Cohen said, I don't think Trump will run
because he's not going to believe he can win and
Trump doesn't want to lose again. That may be,
but it remains to be seen. So just
absolutely pathetic, unhinged posting,
posting, posting to this thing. What is
Trump even doing all day? I do often wonder